so sydney powell is back in the news for  saying something incredibly crazy she is  apparently going around telling people  that former president trump can simply  be reinstated as president and he will  be president  as soon as this summer she said  specifically this is the first case of  abject fraud and obtaining a coup from  the united states of america so it's  going to have to be dealt with  it should be that he can simply be  reinstated that a new inauguration day  is set  and biden is told to move out of the  white house and president trump should  move back in  uh yeah that is not a thing that is  not only the law there is no mechanism  whatsoever that that could possibly  happen yeah that is just hilariously  dumb that is not a thing that's not  going to happen